in the last two three years we've been
facing challenges that we never had to
face before I still have Goosebumps
remember in those days
Steffy is an intensive care nurse
working in London she tells me she's
burnt out and doesn't feel valued by the
government it's why she's voted to
strike it wasn't and it still isn't
unusual to leave work feeling on the
edge
or
walking out of the
of the changing room seeing my
colleagues
crying on the staff room the strike
we're told will not impact emergency
care but other services will be
disrupted
Pat Colin what would you say to a
patient who has been waiting in agony
for months if not years that their
procedure will have to be postponed
again because of your nurses going on
strike this action is about speaking up
for patients it's about ensuring that
those patients don't languish on waiting
lists any longer and they won't if we
are able to fill the vacant posts if
we're able to hold on to the nurses by
giving them a decent wage and ensuring
that this Health Service is fit for
purpose
over the past decade real earnings for
nurses have lagged behind other
professions particularly those in the
private sector
in that time the number of nurses
leaving each year has increased from 27
000 to 38 000. and in June there were
nearly 47 000 nursing vacancies in
England that's the highest on record
the nursing unions insist patient safety
will not be compromised the government
says it has contingency plans in place
next week the NHS carries out exercise
arctic willow to test for its winter
preparedness and also to assess how much
impact the strikes could have on its
services
the government says the nurses demands
add up to an extra 9 billion pounds
that's some six percent of the total NHS
budget
the demand of 17 three times what most
people accept to workers will receive is
out of stat with the economic
circumstances that we face
the nurse's union says its door is open
for negotiations but unless a deal is
reached soon the biggest nurse is
striking over a hundred years is only
weeks away oh she's Josh is Sky News in
central London